hey guys I'm Tiffany Smith with fandango
movie clips with things to know before
you see Fantastic Four and the first
thing to know is that this flick is
going to be fantastic that's my first
and only fantastic joke I promise
now let's get into the details let's
start off with a nerd history lesson the
Fantastic Four was created in 1961 by
comic legend Stan Lee and Jack Kirby it
with Marvel's very first superhero
team-up and was made up of dr. Reed
Richards mr. fantastic do Storm the
invisible woman Johnny Storm the human
torch and Ben Grimm the theme in the
comic the team travels into space in a
rocket where they encounter cosmic rays
that mutate their bodies giving them
their superpowers which is pretty much
what happens in the first two fantastic
four films got it well now forget it
because this movie is a complete reboot
of the Fantastic Four franchise that's
right true believers the new film is
based on the 2004 ultimate Fantastic
Four comic book written by Mark Villar
and Brian Michael Bendis it's darker
grittier and sci-fi year and yes that is
a word in this version the team gets
their powers from doing some
interdimensional travel and spending
some time in the negative zone which is
kind of like the superhero version of
being sent to your room at the helm of
this fantastic flick is josh trank who
also directed chronicle which makes it
easy to see why he's a great fit to tell
a story about people who gained
unexpected powers the film puts together
an amazing cast of young actors starting
with indie darling miles teller as Reed
Richards the whiplash and spectacular
now star also proved his blockbuster
chops in the divergent series Michael B
Jordan eats up the screen as johnny
storm kate mara appears as sue storm who
you'll know from house of cards because
seriously who's not watching that right
am i right like the comics they're
siblings but this time around they're
adopted and rounding out our fearless
foursome is Jamie Bell as Ben Grimm
jamie is the biggest surprise for me
because you may remember him as a wee
lad with happy feet named Billy Elliot
but in this one he's all grown up and
totally rocks as the thing sorry I
couldn't resist and what would a comic
book movie be without a villain enter
Victor Von Doom no ok enter dr. doom
that's right that's in the comics in
this version he's known as Victor DOMA
chef a computer hacker known by his
alias doom not so sure about this one
but the one thing I am sure about is the
actor playing the role Toby Kebbell you
may not recognize his face but you will
recognize his menacing persona if you
saw dawn of the Planet of the Apes he
was Koba so I cannot wait to see what he
does with this role will the
fantastic for saved the world from dooms
do and conquer the box office well we
know there is already a sequel in the
works so fingers crossed make sure you
check out fantastic for when it hits
theaters I'm Tiffany Smith and don't
forget to subscribe to fandango movie
clips and have a fantastic day camps are
you totally knew that was coming
you